you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 16
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
a very important end game and that is
the king queen versus King pawn type now
don't go anywhere
your first impression may have already
been I got this it's all right when I
have a queen I'm going to win when I
have a pond it's unfortunate but I'm
going to lose know if that's your
mentality or similar you really should
be tuned in right now okay because it's
not always a win-loss result there are
plenty of cases more technical cases but
plenty of cases where the result is a
draw are you familiar with them what
conditions must be present in order for
it to be a draw we want to make certain
of something here we want to know what
position types in this end game what
position types are in fact a win and
what ones are in fact a draw okay we
want to make certain we can win the one
positions earn that full point and we
want to make certain we can draw those
drawn positions earn that half point
there's a reason why I'm choosing to
emphasize those terms half and full that
will be revealed a little bit later for
the word half at least but yeah we want
to make sure we can you know distinguish
one from the other okay now do know that
this is a non prerequisite topic I could
have just as well shared this video
within the first few in this playlist
there's no prior information necessary
for you to fully understand everything
that I'm about to share in this video no
prior video you didn't need to watch any
video prior to this one in order to
understand everything that will be
shared here okay and there will be
plenty of topics I share like that like
this in this playlist ones that are of
the stand alone type let's say okay now
as you may come to expect if you've been
tracking this
playlist I like to do things Express
ideas and concepts by way of example
that will go unchanged about what is
going to change slightly is the ending
of this video where I have a pop quiz
for you that you're going to fall in
love with because everybody loves
multiple-choice okay and your choices
are going to be it's a win or it's a
draw and that's really the big question
okay we want to know when it's a win and
when it's a draw okay
and if you're an experienced player
listening right now there may even be a
question that stumps you woo what do I
have up my sleeve okay let's have a look
at our first example the one that we see
before us a we're going to have a very
quick look at in this first example
where it is white to move and just to be
clear and all the examples I share with
you and even during the pop quiz it's
going to be white to move okay so let me
show you what white can do in this
position here to win this position where
the black bond is a mile and a half away
from posing any serious threat to white
very far away from promotion land what
can I do how about Queen d6 for starters
that's nice this pawn is going nowhere
and what does this mean wow we have all
day to improve our King scooped up the
pawn and we're experts once we get here
great let's try another one one that is
much more technical by comparison this
one here who quite aways this guy has
come right now he's only a single step
away okay these are uh these are really
the ones we are going to focus on the
one where the pawn is much closer to
queening it's white to move if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video see
what move you would play here as white
and more importantly try to figure out
is it a win or is it a draw okay the
answer it's a win but you need to be
precise there's only one move here that
will
white to win what is that Queen a one
great similar to what we just saw in the
last example right this is the first
simple point if the Queen can safely
establish herself somewhere in front of
the pawn it's going to be a win the pond
can't bother her position the King can't
even think about approaching the Queen
and we have I've said this phrase just a
moment ago we have all day to go ahead
and hunt that pond down and then win the
King Queen versus King endgame great
we're getting there let's change things
just a hair instead of the king being on
c2 suppose he is now on b2 ooh how is
this different let's see again it's
white to move if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see what move you would
play here as white we certainly don't
want to go a 1 now what move would you
play here as white and is it a win or a
drum okay this is a draw let me just
clear the board there it's a draw am I
kidding you I'm not um maybe a surprise
to many of you you got to be kidding
black only has a pond um I got a queen I
have I have to be able to win no you
can't win why not well let's see Queen
check right we have to do something to
disrupt the black King here because
otherwise black is just going to get a
queen got to try to stop that here's one
way to try to stop that we could give a
check King b1 threatening again check
here what kind of progress is this not
progress at all here's something you
don't want to do is black you don't want
to get in the way of your pond why not
well you always want to be threatening
to promote in the pond and here's
another reason why it's really bad in
this case that's already me
so in other words if we have these
checks here the King just always stays
out of the pawns way but let's try
something else because we're not making
progress by giving these rank checks so
suppose we try some file checks yeah
let's say we go b4 okay King goes to the
corner aha this is the first moment
where we can now improve our King
position right because the pawn can't
move so King g7 right
no games already over stalemate hmm
there's this is really the main issue
this is the reason why white cannot win
it's because black has this stalemate
resource the King just tucks himself
away in the corner and if the Queen does
not open up one of these squares for our
kingdom move - it'll be stalemate so
there's no time to get our King who's
way out of play currently there's no
time to get that King involved in
helping to track down the palm so what
else can be tried I guess you could give
a check another check but it's the same
story Queen here is already stalemate
and that's really the big and that's the
big story here or the little story
involved with a and a pawn of rook pawn
in other words this could also be an H
pawn it's the same thing going on yeah
these guys here who are a single square
away from promotion these will result in
a draw assuming that the white king in
this case side with the king and queen
that king is out of play he's a long way
off from helping to contribute okay
let's have a look at another example
instead of working with an a pawn how
did this position start let's just clear
it out we have this position right here
so now the only thing that's going to
change is instead of having the pawn on
a two we are now working with a pawn on
c2 okay how is this different well let's
see it's white to move if you
like to go ahead pause the video see
what you would do in this position and
is it a win or a draw okay
this too is a draw hmm how well Black's
ready to promote we need to do something
disruptive to the King so this is what
you can try Queen to be for giving a
check along the file King goes to the
corner we don't want to obstruct the
pawn like this because this would be
White's time to now improve the King
position black isn't in stalemate right
here he could go to this square we don't
want to obstruct the pawn King here is
best threatening to promote how can
white stop this you give a check you
could give another check AHA now White
has black right you may be thinking if
the King goes here Queen takes pawn
therefore I have to go to this square
here to defend the pawn because I don't
want to lose my pawn right Crom you
should be going to the corner knowing
full well that this pawn if taken will
result in stalemate this is another pawn
there's the a pawn there's the C pawn
and also these corresponding squares is
corresponding file pawns the F pawn and
H fun that when one square away from
promotion when the king is close by to
aid in that pawns advance and I know
there's a lot of little conditions here
and the enemy King here the White King
in this case is a long ways off from
helping to contribute these are all
cases all situations where the end
results will be a draw let me just put
that up there a pawn C pawn F pawn H
pawn
now a little tip it will require a
little bit of your imagination here but
a little tip that you can use and just
as a reminder you know how are you -
maybe remember that these are the puns
that will result in a draw or that
half-point well let's see we have the H
pun the letter H letter A the letter C
and if just use your imagination a
little bit just suppose that the letter
C just turned into a person for a moment
and kind of stretched out kind of turns
into the letter L and we have the letter
F we have these pawns here these file
pawns basically spelling out the word
half okay these are the ones that will
result in that half point again they
need to be a single square away from
promoting the enemy Kane needs to be far
away like in the examples he was on h8
and our King needs to be near the action
of course the black king in these cases
needs to be near the action helping to
aid in that pawns advance and of course
the Queen we of course can't allow the
Queen to position herself in front of
those prongs so there's a lot of little
conditions but yeah these are the file
pawns the H file the a file the C file
that I'm having you imagine as an L for
a moment just to create that word half
and the F pun okay these are the ones
that can result in a draw using those
stalemate resources okay
well you may be curious about a
different pun ones that we haven't
touched on like a deep on or a center
pun whether it's a deep on or an e pawn
it's going to be the same story okay
what about now can we finally win this
position well I'll put it to you if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what you can come up with is this a
win or is this a draw and what would you
do
okay the solution it's a win how though
what is the method what is an approach
we can take in order to win this
position well let's see we can start
first with the move Queen to e4 and
maybe let me just back up for a moment
there are some key squares to be
familiar with look what are these key
squares well it's the squares right
behind the pawn the d3 Square and its
neighbors III and c3 these are the three
key squares our queen will do very well
to be positioned on d3 III c3 she does a
very good job why well we're going to
see that soon enough just a quick note
she gives check often and keeps pressure
on this pawn from all three of these
squares she'll always put pressure on
the pawn from all three of these squares
and sometimes even be giving check so
she'll have a great influence in other
words on both of the black pieces the
King and pawn so an excellent start
knowing that we want to get to these
three key squares these ones right here
an excellent start is going to form now
we have a couple squares we can make use
of next Kings in check King f1 we give
another check and get to that one key
squared d3 the King has to now go to e1
to defend the pawn and now we make use
of another key Square III pressure on
the pawn giving check and what are we
doing with this last move we are forcing
the King to go to d1 as otherwise we win
the pun and once the king is on d1 this
is when our King's eyes should light up
this is his moment to run to the rescue
right this is this is his moment to
approach the pawn King g7 as soon as
this pawn can't move that's when our
King improves his position
King si - its back on where the pawn is
ready to move we need to do similar and
eventually force the King back in front
of the punch so that our King could
slowly improve his position take some
work we give another file check file
checks are very good do know this what
what is maybe a reason why let's say a
file check is a good idea when compared
to let's say a rank check if you could
just imagine a king being checked along
a rank there is the possibility for a
pawn to move when he is checked by a
queen along a rank let me see if I could
just illustrate this real quick suppose
we just have this check for a moment and
the King goes here and now we can do
something like this right what are we
doing we're giving a check along a rank
the King doesn't necessarily have to
move when there's a rank check does he
in this case absolutely not the pond
could move and block the check and get
the Queen why am i covering this it's
because when you give file checks it's
impossible for the pawn to move and
block a file check and that's a good
that's good news for us because we don't
want this pawn to move forward doing
King D 3 Queen d5 king e 2 and we move
forward
Queeny for King F to wear wooden at one
of those key squares d3 king has to go
to e1 to defend upon and we're already
seeing a pattern we've been here before
making use of d3 and then III it can
happen where we make use of d3 and then
even go to c3 King has to go to d1 he's
now blocking the pawn our Kings eyes
light up here he comes
king c2 and here we go King d3 Queen d5
the King now goes to c2 but also let me
point out suppose the King goes to one
of these two and says you know I'm not
going to allow your queen to
you know meet king c2 with King c4 and
meet King II - with King efore I'm just
going to go here well in this position
is the pawn even threatening to promote
successfully no we can improve the King
here you promote we take the Queen to be
a little bit careful right it's not
stalemate there's actually one square
for the king to go to but the short
story here is that on this check the
king is going to one of these to the
pawn isn't even threatening to queen
successfully okay well in this example
he goes to c2 now we approach these
three key squares Queen c4 width check
King be one Queen d3 King c1 has to go
there to defend the pawn and now similar
pattern going on except this time on the
other side making use of c3 King has to
go and block the pond here comes our
King and it's the same story we give
these file checks we're getting we're
making use of these three key squares d3
III King is blocked here comes our King
we can make use of d3 straight away now
that our King is this close kinks Queen
c3 the blocking one more and look at how
far our King has come just a couple
moves away now from not only picking up
the pawn but giving check mate okay so
what have we learned here well a center
pawn a deep on or an e pawn a single
square away from promoting will be a win
okay we could go ahead and win by making
use of in this case by making use of
these three key squares and eventually
forcing the King to obstruct the pawn
and then that is our our moment for our
King to slowly make some progress okay a
lot of lot of Queen moves and then a
King move a lot of Queen moves and then
a King move okay let's have a look at
another example instead of a a center
pawn
let's have a look at the B pond
and what we'll soon find out is that
there's something similar going on with
this you know keeping an eye on these
three key squares we can first start
with this file check King b3 Queen b5
King to one of these two is not
threatening to promote King c2 King c4
one of the key squares pressure on both
pieces the King now has to obstruct the
pawn here comes our King King a2 and
this is a little bit different this next
move and it involves the knight pawns
here's a nice little move for the Queen
Queen c2 let me just point out that if
the King goes to a3 simple enough right
upon is stopped cold and we can move our
King multiple times in a row and
eventually scoop him up so what does
this mean after king c2 King a3 we go
here so therefore King a1 and now in
just one move Queen a4 he's immediately
forced to be one time to move the King
because the pawn can't move King f6 King
c1 can only move we give some more file
checks eventually making use of again
these three key squares so hopefully
you're seeing the pattern here Queen c2
King a1 she's revisiting a four it's the
same story over and over pawn is blocked
that's our time for the King to improve
making use of those three key squares
behind that pond and eventually we will
be mating actually we don't even have to
pick up the pawn here we can just mate
with Queen c2 not the only way to win a
longer way is to go here pin the pawn
and next win the pond and eventually
hunt down the king but yeah this would
work too huh
checkmate just straight away with the
pawn still on board okay so this is the
big thing to take away thus farm
we already saw with the H pawn the a
pawn the C pawn that I had you imagine
stretch out to an L and the F pawn
forming the word half those guys result
in that half point that drop whereas
these guys here they could be one step
away but that's alright we'll be able to
go on to win okay let's have a look
another example not many more here
before that pop quiz suppose we are now
working with this one right here where
we have an a pond who is two squares
away from queening we already know that
if the pond was here it would be a draw
and you know just from knowing that
piece of information this is already
influencing a position that's one ply
back you know want one moved back
now that we know if he gets to this
square here it's going to be a drum we
can't let that happen you know it may be
very tempting to be like okay well my
king he's way out of play let's get him
going
no after pond here oh it's a draw one
wrong slip you have to know that this
position is a draw and because of that
you shouldn't be moving your king what
should white do Queen to be five giving
a file check King a one he wants to
allow this pond to move and now we can
actually do something a little bit
clever here as White Queen see four oh
but this is allowing the pawn to move
well actually we have a threat in mind
if the pawn goes to a 2 that is
checkmate so this is a nice little trick
to be familiar with this these
checkmates on c1 or even f1 when our
opponent is trying to promote the rook
pawns getting the Queen to those squares
and those two squares Queen c4 is a fine
move here a 2 is met with checkmate
so black has to do something else King 2
B 2 and now we make use of B 4 okay we
don't have three squares you know when
we have a center pond where I add three
key squares there's only two key squares
behind the pond that we should be
looking to get to okay and we could do
that after King B - Queen B 4 where does
the King go King a - and now that the
pawn is blocked we can improve
our king and know that on blacks next
move guess where he has to go he has to
go to a1 there's only one legal move
here and we can just scoop up the pond
it's very important again from this
initial position we don't think hey our
King is out of play let's get them going
no this pawn gets here black will be
able to draw unless you know there's
that situation where we could
immediately make use of c1 straight away
as soon as the pawn moves and the king
is in the corner but yeah you can't just
think about improving your King here you
have to recognize this position here is
a drop so let's not allow black to
acquire that position giving checks is
the is the correct approach here with
the Queen eventually getting to these
key squares b4 in this case and soon we
just scoop the pawn up let's have a look
at one more example here this time
involving the C pawn
if you happen to be a more experienced
player tuned in right now you might even
take something away from this example
here there's a nice efficient position
that I'll be highlighting here so we
have a case where we're working with AC
p-- on that letter C stretched out as an
L this is one of those if he is on this
square right here it's one of those half
point pawns okay we can't allow this guy
to get to see - there's only one move we
could deal here that will successfully
stop its advance it's the move Queen to
e5 taking advantage of this pin now what
does black do King to b3 Queen d4 is an
excellent post for the white king or
excuse me the white queen why striking
at this pawn along a diagonal like this
is excellent when we have a poem like
this that is two squares away from
promoting if we can put pressure on it
along a diagonal like this the d4 post
is excellent let me explain from this
position where can the black King be
where he defends the c3 pawn what
squares must he be on in order for the
pawn to stay defended he has to be on b3
b2 or c2 okay these squares are are
blocked off by the White Queen she's a
very very close by stopping the King
from being on other squares where he
could defend the pawn so there's only
three squares where the King can still
be defending the pawn it's black to move
and also know that if the king is on b2
or c2 the pawn is not threatening to
move which means we can improve our King
position why can't the pawn move aJE's
on c2 this should be clear what about if
he's on b2 well the pawn is in a pin
so the only square the King could really
stay on and have the pawn move is on b3
so suppose the pawn moves is this a draw
it's not and the reason for that is
because we can make use of first a1 and
then we are guaranteed to get to c1 next
safely okay we can't just pick any of
any route you know we can't just go here
with check thinking we're going to get
here next no because of king b2 and
we're not getting here and the results
will be a draw so the short story here
is that this efficient post by the White
Queen when we have a pond that's a
couple squares away from promoting
striking at this pond along a diagonal
like this really does a good job in
stopping the pond from moving and yeah
either stopping the pond for moving
because it's illegal like this or you
know like this because the king is in
the way and if the pond does move we go
here and in here next and then it's a
very fast track to approaching the pond
okay
so we would actually it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be like this example here where
we had the D pawn with just him being
one Square way from queening where we
would have to make multiple clean moves
you know multiple Queen moves and then a
king move multiple Queen moves
and then it can move it wouldn't be like
that when the pond is two squares away
from cleaning we can actually just keep
moving our King keep moving our King
knowing that you know this pond isn't
going to go anywhere and if he tries to
move a quick a1 to c1 and he stopped
cold okay let's have a look at just one
more example and then we're going to
have three three more examples and then
that test pop quiz
maybe you don't like the term test okay
here you go one more where we're working
with an e pond two squares away even if
I mean we already covered a center pond
one square away so if it's a a center
pond or even a be pond that's now let me
just highlight them if these are the
file ponds that are one square way it's
to win so as you might expect if the
pawn is two steps away that two will be
a win okay that's just a very quick
point I wanted to make with that example
and now these last two are working with
now the King finally being a little bit
closer to the action just to give you a
feel for these positions suppose that
the King is a little bit more involved
in trying to hunt down the F pond one of
the ponds that sometimes can result in a
draw well it's not going to be a draw
here and let's see why mmm the King is
closer he's a he's close enough let's
say in this position he's just a single
square away black is working with one of
the bishop ponds the C pawn F pawn one
square way with those guys
the king is just a move away from
getting to this key third-ranked we can
start with Queenie to king g1 just a
quick note if King h1 we don't want to
take here that stalemate what what we
could do is improve our king like this
and pick up the pawn next or maybe even
give checkmate soon yeah I mean just a
couple from here but in this position he
goes to g1 we can improve our King now
we can actually allow the pond to
promote King g3 allows f1 equals Queen
because we can give mate on h2 black can
do something fancy like promote here and
get a night that would give check we
would just scoot out of the way and mate
would soon follow after that the main
idea here is that the king is closer to
the action so it's not always oh it's a
it's an F pawn who's won square away
from queening and our King is there to
support its advance it's going to be a
draw because of that stalemate resource
no that was when the king was a long
ways away we don't have that the timing
is just not right because the king is
closer to the action here okay let's
have a look at just one more example
where the king is closer this time
working with a rip on he can in fact be
even a couple squares away from this key
third rank when working with a rip on
and it will still be a win first move
Queen e2 if he goes to g3 we'll be able
to get here
goes to g1 we can improve the King allow
black to get a queen and even play King
g3 and there is not a successful check
that the black queen can give white here
there's one tricky little move maybe
with Queen f3 trying to get white to
take the Queen with the Queen because
that would be stalemate but White has
another option King takes Queen King in
the corner has black has a legal move
and then we can give me short story here
is that the king is close enough he's
within a couple ranks when fighting
against this rook pawn from promoting
can actually allow black to get a queen
improve the King and then be in this
position where there is not a good move
we have all sorts of mates lined up
against black and again not a good check
for black to throw a light okay I
believe that is all the examples I have
for you and so at this point and as
mentioned at the start I now have a
group of 10 puzzles to share with your
10/10 problems where if you'd like to at
this point and I would encourage this is
that you just take out a piece of paper
and Mark it one through ten your answers
are either going to be W or a d4 it's a
win or it's a drop and I'm initially
going to just present all ten of these
problems I will give you a few seconds
to go ahead and pause the video while
the puzzle position stays up there spend
as long as you want
trying to work it out and then unpause
it and you'll see what puzzle 2 is I'm
just going to be giving a few seconds
with each of these puzzles to show them
and then I'm going to revisit them and
show you the solutions or in most cases
just tell you what the solution is and
in some cases do a little bit of
explaining okay so here we go with that
said get ready for the first one again
I'll just going to be giving
a few seconds with each of these and do
know it is white to move in each case
here is the first one giving you just a
few seconds
is it a win or is it a draw three two
one
okay here comes puzzle problem number
two
three-two-one
here comes problem number three
is it a win is it a draw it's the same
question for each of these three two one
here comes number four
three-two-one here's number five coming
up few seconds for this for you to pause
okay here comes number six
three-two-one
okay here comes number seven
three-two-one number eight just a few
more problem number eight right here
problem number nine coming up here is
problem nine not okay and here is the
final problem number 10 so spend as long
as you want with these okay and now for
the answers so let's just go through
here assuming I'm hopeful that many of
you actually did take out a piece of
paper and you know write the numbers one
through ten out and just had a quick
little W or a D for each of the answers
so let's see how you did
problem number one let's see how well
you grasp this topic it's okay if you uh
you know make some mistakes you know
that's maybe your hint - maybe rewatch a
part of this video or not okay that's
that's on you of course but okay problem
number one if you set it's a win well
done the first one is a win for white
number two
this is also a w-2 double use in a row
so what does that mean there's got to be
it means number three has to be a draw
right that's what you think and if you
thought this one was a draw problem
number three here you are right this is
a draw so far so good right how we doing
three four three four the majority of
you I hope I'm on number four
win or a draw this is a win two squares
away that's a win number five
this is a drum or working with one of
those you know h a CF that letters see
ahead you envision stretching out as an
L those are the half point ponds the
drawing ponds one square away number six
puzzle
ah
this is a win for white number seven
actually let me point out why this is a
win I could give a check along the file
King here and similar to what we had
before I've showed a showed shown excuse
me you know an ape on a couple squares
away from queening Queen c6 prevents
this advance because of Queen c1 so this
is something to keep in the back of your
mind you know so King here we could go
to the square without fear of a - can be
- we could slowly get behind here
continually threatened Queen c1 should
the pawn push and eventually we get to
those key squares right now we can move
the King and then scoop up the pawn so
this is again problem six and it is a
win let's have a look at number seven
also number seven and this is maybe one
of the more tricky ones because now we
have the King a little bit closer but is
he close enough he isn't close enough he
needs to actually be one more rank
closer this one may have stumped too
many of you this is a draw you can
review that part of the video - to
refresh your understanding of that
here's number eight
is it a win or a draw this is a win may
even be been very close to identical to
how I presented it this is a when the
king is close enough King g4 promote
King g3 a little bit of calculation few
moves deep there this is a one position
number nine
this is also a win don't lose sight
Queen a1 we saw we saw that very early
on it could be very easy to be caught up
in oh is the king close enough oh we're
working with a rook pawn that's only a
single square away it's a draw
no the Queen could go here just in the
nick of time and this will be a win and
the last example last problem number 10
have any of you got 9 for 9 up until
this point
are you going to get 10 for 10 the
results the answer for this one is and
don't be upset if you didn't get this
one correct it's okay this one is a draw
okay I think many of you may have chalk
this one up as a W but let me explain
this is because of this example here and
I'm sure there are many others not too
many but because of an example like this
it's how to say because there are
situations like this on board I can't
say well when any of the pawns are two
squares away from promoting it's always
a win I can't say that because here's a
case where it's not a win and upon is
two squares away from queening hmm well
a lot of interesting things have to be
present on board in order for this to
actually be a draw and that's what we're
faced with here the pawn is ready to
promote our excuse me ready to get to
see to where he has one square way from
promoting and we know if this is
achieved it will be a drawn position so
we can try Queen b7 check okay there
really isn't any other way we can stop
this pawn from moving
we can play Queen b7 check and now there
is one move that will save the draw
there's an only move for black king c1
threatening to get the pawn 1 square
away from queening there isn't a
diagonal check that white can give to
black right you can't get on this
diagonal or this one here safely so how
else do you stop the pawn from pushing
besides returning to the square you came
from on h1 after king b2 we're just
repeating moves there's no good way
forward here and it's it's a very
atypical position rare position but yeah
the Queen is in the corner
this King is actually getting in the way
of white going on to win notice if the
King wasn't on h8 suppose this position
began you know let me just make a couple
moves here to get the King on a
different square if he's not on h8
now it's a win why because the Queen
could go to H a and similar to what I
showed when the Queen was on this square
here D for cutting into the the pawns
striking at the pawn along a diagonal
it's a similar story here if the King is
going to see to well our excuse me the
the Queen could just go to d4 next
actually right once she's on h8 she can
next go to d4 and we have that same
position right this should look familiar
so it I just wanted to point out and
again that's the reason why I really
wanted to when presenting this topic I
really wanted to be able to give that
type of information to you like hey when
the pawn is two squares away from
queening I don't care what file it's on
it's always a win no I can't say that
because this is an example here where no
it's actually not going to be a win okay
I really like to share you know that
kind of cut and dry type of information
that black and white type of phrase I
really want to do something like that
but here's a case now you know because
of this situation I can't I couldn't do
that
okay but it's almost always the case
well where when one of the pawns is two
squares away from promoting you know it
doesn't matter what file it's on it's
almost almost always a win okay so there
was a lot covered here as usual I've
lost track of how long the videos been
going on
it's an involved endgame okay there's a
lot of different details here feel free
in the comment section below to let me
know how you did with the little test
don't again don't be too upset
especially for this last example here I
imagine it it uh you know it stumped
many I would not be surprised if an
experienced player chimed in and said
hey you know if they were being just
completely honest and open about it you
know I wouldn't be surprised if they
maybe even stumbled on this one as well
but you know use that as a use that
little test as some type of gauge to you
know see how well you really digested
what was delivered here maybe something
you have to rewatch maybe just part of
it here there but yeah okay King and
pawn or excuse me King and Queen versus
King and pawn that can be tricky right
there's some there's some drawers
there's some wins we need to know the
difference between the two and this will
help us make better decisions before we
even get to these simplified points in a
game okay so as usual I hope you got
something out of this video again leave
some feedback in the comment section
below let me know how you did on that
test did anybody go ten for ten
let me know in the comment section below
and I look forward to sharing video 17
with you so that's all for now take care
bye
you